shouts out to ravanthan chori who says
people how many videos about no way home
are you gonna make before the movie
comes greg and john
yes
meanwhile cosmic wonder in the
background hold my beer guys we're gonna
watch from cosmic wonder today
spider-man no way home post-credits
scene venom cameo possible a movie denis
villanue is so excited for it but guys i
gotta tell you really quick the dream i
had last night so i was uh stationed at
a hotel and uh brad pitt was the person
i was mainly rooming with the whole time
he was telling all these like glorious
stories
that he had on set it was just such a
delight but then things got really
uncomfortable and weird when my mom
because at this point in the story i've
been like friends with brad pitt for
like a few years now and then my mom
showed up with like all my relatives who
like brad pitt had met like one time and
they all acted like hey brad hart and he
had to like act like he knew all their
names but he couldn't really remember
them it was just so
embarrassing how family can be when
you're around your famous friends hey
who let's watch this
[Music]
how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder i'm your host warren
thompson and it looks like venom could
be making his way to the mcu actually it
looks like venom might already be in the
marvel cinematic universe there's been a
lot of talk recently about venom and
spider-man crossing paths in some
universe sooner than later in fact venom
let there be carnage director andy
circus has said that spider-man and
venom will indeed go face to face
sometime in the future he told that to
ign the other day and what's really
curious about this is that we're getting
this information at the same time that
we're getting all of these rumors about
the venom let there be carnage post
credit scene and i actually think that
we might have gotten a little insight
from tom hardy venom himself on what
spider-man no way home's post-credit
scene might actually be
guessed it i'm sure i'm thinking that
one of the post-credit scenes in
spider-man no way home could be about
venom i guessed it from your title man
got it from your title let's start off
by talking about the fact that andy
serkis the director of venom 2 confirmed
to the world the other day that venom
and spider-man are eventually going to
meet and fight as i mentioned he did an
interview with ign about venom let there
be carnage and of course he was asked
about spider-man i love how any single
time anyone from sony in that arena of
the film can you say anything remotely
close to yeah it's like kind of a
development yeah it might have happened
it's like years headline oh my god yes
because it hasn't done it for years we
know we know however when it comes to
the director of the most recent venom
movie that holds more credence to the
possibility that it could happen sooner
than
usual i will say
in which he said this everyone wants to
know when venom is going to meet
spider-man personally it's not going to
happen i'm kidding it's going to happen
the question is when we don't want to
rush it so we no longer
and about a month ago tom hardy also
came out and said that he is going to
push for venom 3 to be a venom vs
spider-man film so andy circus says that
it's going to happen and tom hardy says
that he's gonna do whatever he can do to
make it happen so i'm gonna assume it's
gonna happen what i really really want
though as much as i i love the prospect
that the two toms meeting on screen and
going toe-to-toe like i want that to
happen at the same time what i really do
want is for peter parker to have the
story of the symbiote attaching itself
to him and then dealing with all the
repercussions of course experiencing the
benefits of having it but then the
downfall because that's such a classic
spider-man story that was not executed
the best it could be in spider-man 3 and
i feel like it's such an integral part
to why venom himself is so antagonistic
towards peter parker spider-man and a
big part of it is the rejection of the
symbiote that peter parker eventually
takes on i feel like that's just an
integral part i don't know how they
would do it maybe a different symbiote
but that's just something i would really
want for uh
the tom holland one you know you know
i'm saying bitly everyone knows what i'm
saying and obviously they know more than
they're telling us and this could
actually affect spider-man no way home
or should i say spider-man no way home
could drastically affect venom vs
spider-man especially if you consider
the rumors going around about venom let
there be carnage's post-credit scene the
rumor is that the post-credits scene
will connect to tom holland spider-man
in some way shape or form really cause i
have heard all of the rumors about it in
detail i'm just not going into detail in
case some of those people out there
don't want those spoilers but if the
rumors end but your cosmic wonder
is spider-man related
spider-man this does heavily imply that
the two of them are going to meet and it
actually applies that they'll meet
sooner rather than later and here's the
big news last night tom hardy gave us
more to look into he posted a picture of
himself wearing a spider-man no way home
hat that was given to the crew of no way
home
this doesn't mean that he's in the movie
someone could have just given this to
him however considering that he is in
code
that we've gotten recently there is a
possibility that he is in the movie and
if he is actually in the movie i have to
give them credit i guess because this is
the one secret that they were able to
keep from us although i guess if we're
talking about this and it ends up being
true it wasn't really a well-kept secret
so
yeah but there are actually a couple of
ways that venom could appear in
spider-man now a home that actually make
a ton of sense they recently had a fan
screening event where tom hardy and andy
circus were there and for some reason
they put their faith in the fans that
they wouldn't spoil the post-credits
scene
but
you know you can't do that
valiant effort especially if the
post-credits scene is of that caliber
he's rocking that spider-man no way home
hat could just be showing the support
you know if it is the crew member hat
yeah that does well you know a couple
days as a gaffer or something yeah he
kicks someone's ass to get that hat
some poor pa and he's also in cobra kai
now because he's got the kind of t-shirt
so yeah he's in both properties
confirmed that's what brings uh the
dojos together
frog takes over for miyagi doe and then
yeah unites the valley and that's why
spider-man just can't handle it and
since the venom let there be carnage
post-credit scene is rumored to be about
spider-man it would make sense that the
spider-man know a home post credits
scene could be about venom especially if
that is spider-man's next can you
imagine that our goal is everything that
comes true i fully believe it will but
you never know but let's say everything
comes true toby mcguire shows up andrew
garfield shows up and we already know
all of the villains are going to show up
and it's all just going to be pretty
epic so how do you out do that in the
next film where do you go from here well
the one thing that we wouldn't have seen
in this movie is venom spider-man
finally going up against venom this
could be sony and marvel's next move
finally due with spider-man vs venom
film the other way that venom could
appear in spider-man no way home is that
he could be the sixth member of the
sinister six right now we only know five
villains of the sinister six even some
of the leaks that we've had that were
pretty accurate say that they don't know
who the sixth villain is could the sixth
one be venom is this why nobody knows
who the sixth villain is because it's
such a big secret because it's so big i
admit that this one is a little
and i wouldn't bet any money on it
happening but dang would it be cool if
venom was the sixth member because you
could totally have venom with all of
these other classic villains but then
you could still have a venomverse
spider-man film because this film could
set up the next one i don't believe that
one bit
to be totally transparent because um
it's definitely rhino that's why
i think it's not going to happen because
all the villains are somewhat already
connected through past experiences with
their respective spider-man whereas
venom has never met spider-man so just
me there's a whole new plot that you'd
have to introduce and plus i wouldn't
really like it for spider-man no way
home because i'm like if you're finally
gonna have this venom we've been
building in the spider-man building to
finally meet it should be a stand-alone
movie that i believe would be a sony
film i don't know if it would be a
marvel film if that makes like an emcee
oh yeah i think it would have to be a
sony film i don't think kevin feige
no
i don't think he wants the oohs of the
symbiote all over here no i don't think
so either sony spiderman version what's
it called what sony's spiderman
you gotta keep up to date with the news
this is why it's knee villain you does
not like you know copy and paste all my
answers but let me know what you think
about all of this do you think that
we're going to see venom and spider-man
no way home in some way shape or form
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
it's weird to see your face when you see
that and uh also i would say that
i think just by
um virtue alone the fact that that they
have the daily bugle and he's showcasing
the trailer that already is an indicator
that j jonah jameson at the very least
exist in the venom universe spider-man's
coming that'll be what venom three is
actually about is just eddie brock
competing with a very young peter parker
to get a job at the daily yeah
all right guys well leave your thoughts
down below thank you warren for putting
this video together spider warden
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button we'll catch jesus
christ soon
you